hey everybody and welcome to a wild ride
with stevo which people
have been begging for for real i think
that i've seen more requests
for steve will do it than maybe even
johnny knoxville
man and what a crazy time we had
dude he's one of the milk boys they are
absolutely
on fire and this episode
is insane ladies and gentlemen
steve will do it yeah dude
it's great to be here man brother thank
you man people have been
begging a lot of the comments are like
get steve will do it on get steve will
do it on which is crazy to me because
it's like
this guy grew up [ __ ] you know
looking up to loving him so
you know for anyone to say to stevo get
steve on her
crazy well dude let me tell you that i
appreciate
the the praise i appreciate uh the love
um and let's be honest dude
you're on fire like you're on
fire thank you you feel like you're on
fire i feel like um
i'm killing it but i'm on the right path
like i'm just i'm just doing what i
how old are you 22. 22. oh my god
22. yeah jesus that's so crazy to me
um now the milk boys there's two milk
boys
yeah there's uh me kyle
saleem and lucas so there's four
yeah okay i thought there was just two
no
um is it competitive between you guys
like i know i
worked with the side men and like ksi
was just so
far away in front of me no because we're
uh we're all a team
you know like kyle you know he's the
main guy like
say if steve will do it's getting
[ __ ] five million views an episode
it's like he's happy for me because
we're all team you know
right rolling stones are a team yeah but
there's mick jagger dude
right keith richards there's there's
nothing like that with us because it's
like if i'm winning they're winning
because uh the loyalty we have you know
i've always felt the same way about
johnny knoxville yeah you know like uh
him being successful just makes me more
successful
yeah that's that's how it is with us
it's like if kyle's
if nelk's going crazy then i'm going
crazy if i'm going crazy then that's
going crazy we're all happy for each
other we're all
it's all one team that's great you don't
do a lot of podcasts huh
no actually i've been asked to do many
podcasts and especially this one tim
dillon i don't know if you know tim
dillon sure
he's on fire he's he's one of my
favorite podcasts and he asked me months
ago like
he's my favorite podcast he asked me
like yo can you please come on podcast
i'm like no
because i uh i'm not the best talker and
i feel like i
may or not may or may not have autism
that's how i feel
i mean dude you're uh you seem to be
talking great with me man
and uh i think that your your career
is evident you know thank you yeah but
yeah so
i i let me just say before we even
continue that my ear
[ __ ] hurts i know uh presumably this
will come out after
we've both posted footage of the pooh
cannon
which is something i just dreadfully
failed to think through
i don't know what i put i just put my
ear there
i mean dude i dialed up the psi
pounds per square inch is that what it
is yeah dude
i died i did we filled up a poo cannon
and
blasted my ear and it just straight
rocked my eardrum
and filled my ear canal with dog [ __ ]
with wendy's poop
yeah wendy among three other dogs four
different dogs were in the blood oh wow
yeah so where's that video going to play
or where is it playing as we speak
is gonna put it on his youtube vlog and
i'm gonna put it on my
youtube blog i sent it to my girl she
says dude
save this for something bigger than
youtube and i said yeah well
this was with the milk boys like pretty
big pretty pretty worth it it's bigger
than youtube yeah super worth it to go
big
oh [ __ ] you keep doing that i know it's
like
when you're like the you do the pressure
change you know like it's just
really sensitive in there too so the
doctor didn't say that like yo there's a
lot of poop they were like there was a
lot of wax well the thing much
the thing that bummed me out was it was
a physician's assistant and i'm not
talking
[ __ ] about physician's assistants but
like they're not doctors
that's what the old guy was because this
thing said physician's assistant
so i'm like maybe we should go see a
doctor open-minded
to going to uh a proper doctor because
yeah it is it is pretty messed up
um but i gotta do this and then i gotta
do uh
an interview for shark week dude my
buddy got his hand
mangled by a shark like mangled you get
cut off or what
not cut off but mangled to where like
see if you hold
your wrist like that it stops here yeah
this is [ __ ] and poopies dude
they're flying like dangling by a tendon
all the way it was it was it was
flopped all 10 minutes gone and he had
to have surgery to reattach tendons and
two severed arteries oh my gosh he would
be so [ __ ] dead if they didn't dive
on him as fast as they did and [ __ ]
get him out of there
jesus he got [ __ ] wrecked by a shark
that's crazy for a shark week episode
and uh he and i got to do um an
interview together to talk about it
right after uh
after we do this but let me get back on
track let me get focused here because
what i told you earlier
and i'm genuinely concerned and this is
in no way like some kind of an attack
or i'm trying to get you or anything but
i'm legitimately curious
looking at all of your postings all of
your texts all
of you know you just spent a million
dollars on a single youtube video
you're giving out bitcoins which are 30
grand to like people if they comment
on an instagram post like you're buying
cars for people like it's no big deal
you're throwing away jewelry off
balconies like diamonds necklaces you're
tossing them off balconies
i mean you are being so reckless with
money
i have to try to figure out i can't help
but be so curious
if you're like highly strategic and very
calculated
in all of these moves where you're
you're spending money to make money
or if you're just [ __ ] out of control
or if you just like have that much money
that you genuinely don't care but
in this day and age it's a pretty wild
move like you know because
like like the way i look at the world
and i know i'm talking a lot i gotta let
you get in here it's so funny yeah like
let me just just shut the [ __ ] up no no
no no keep going keep on hilarious okay
the way i look at the world
the the the one percent has all the
money and everyone else is [ __ ] hurt
you know so to have a lifestyle where
you're like
like kind of flossing where you're like
like you know showing how much
wealth you have and spending money and
throwing money around
like i think a lot of you know
man i don't have that much money but
like i'm sensitive to it you know like i
wouldn't want to
be like have never wanted to be flashy
you know and like i know that
when you're throwing around money you're
typically giving it away to people
you're being
like uh you know what you call it like a
philanthropist
you know you're being a kind and
generous person which is cool
but what are your thoughts about being
only [ __ ] 22 years old
and and throwing like does any part of
you think i gotta be careful and save
just because [ __ ] i might live until i'm
80. i hate to put the kid on blast but i
felt like i needed to tell
him to look out for his future it's
important
dude and you know what the best way to
look out for your future is
to make sure you are insured
and it doesn't have to be a hassle if
you go to policygenius.com
why would you do that because that's
where you can compare quotes from over a
dozen top insurers
and why is that important because when
you do it that way you can save over
50 percent on your life insurance i'm
telling you that's like
over 1300 bucks maybe that you can party
with this summer
and you'll be taking care of your
business knowing that you're doing the
right thing looking out for your future
and
the future of your loved ones so it's
hassle free you go to policy
policygenius.com within minutes
you figure out what you need and then
when you're ready to apply the policy
genius team sets everything up for you
schedules it and they do it all for free
so get yourself insured take care of
your business
at policygenius.com man when it comes to
insurance
it's nice to get it right now let's get
back to steve we'll do it
no and no
so there's zero part of me that feels
like that way
because um i'm so like confident in
myself
because like if i'm tripping like five
years from now
about a hundred thousand dollars two
hundred thousand
a million three million four million
whatever then that means i failed my
mission right
okay so so i'm uh on that path to to
not fail and that's how much i believe
in myself and what i do
but at the same time like no matter what
how much i believe in
believe in myself every dumb purchase i
do there's a smart purchase right you
know it's like
you know i probably own like seven
million in real estate just over
so every every if i give away 300 000
like i probably bought
a condo or something you know it's like
you know what i'm saying so i just was
kind of like
like right now like i could get i could
lose everything and so yeah then today
it's like i got
seven million or whatever in in condos
and houses and [ __ ]
right but i don't care like if i have
you know um i believe in myself
so much right now and what and
and what what i'm about to do if i'm
tripping about a million dollars
then that means i failed so all right
what is your mission
to be a billionaire you gonna be a
billionaire all right to be a
billionaire yeah do you have a timeline
for that
three to five years three to five years
damn yeah so
like pardon my ignorance but uh
how did you come into this situation
just straight youtube
you just no dude so i had a really
shitty [ __ ] day right like when i was
young i was young as [ __ ]
and uh at that point i hated my life
this night i was like yo like i'm sick
of this like
and then i started making instagram
videos like i'm like i'm done with this
[ __ ]
and i always thought that i would be
like uh like a
streamer like i would stream and work
out and be that youtube
guy because i would watch like for
example like faze boyz
face clan i'd watch them when i was
younger i was like yo this this guy just
bought like
a flat screen tv like that's crazy like
i want a flat screen tv
right those guys throw money around
pretty much what i'm saying but it's
like but it was like i had like
the shittiest day of my life and i was
like you know what [ __ ] this like
i'm i'm doing this and that's when i
started um
drinking liquor on instagram okay so i
started
the first video when you're in high
school in high school yeah and i was on
probation
for what for marijuana okay yeah i got
arrested like three times for marijuana
it's ridiculous
where what state did you grow up in in
florida florida ridiculous where in
florida
uh near orlando oviedo florida but it
was like i had the shittiest day of my
life and he was like
i was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone like
i'm gonna do this [ __ ] and then i posted
a video of me slamming a whole bottle of
fireball and it was like it was crazy
because i gained like hundreds of
followers i was like yo like i'm the
[ __ ]
like you know man i never had good
things happen when i chugged hard liquor
it was oh every time it was bad
well news one time my buddy and i
[ __ ]
chugged big huge glasses of whiskey
and then we blacked out we didn't know
what happened turns out my buddy
fell through a [ __ ] glass door
straight glass door he fell down
and he landed on it like this jagged on
the bottom cut his elbow all the way
through everything to [ __ ] cut it
through the bone
and like he would have been dead bled
out
except for the neighbor heard the
[ __ ] glass break and thought there
was a [ __ ] break-in
they thought that the house was being
burgled so they called the cops and the
cops came and found us
both unconscious in the gnarliest
[ __ ] pool of blood you've ever seen
like that's the only reason that
[ __ ] didn't die
another time dude i woke up on the hood
of a [ __ ] car because i had crashed
my bicycle
[ __ ] out of my teeth the first time i
broke teeth dude
so you were driving i was riding my
bicycle home and i [ __ ] and
next thing you know i'm on the hood of a
parked car so you were
you were [ __ ] up yeah yeah i blacked
out every time i chugged hard liquor
but it worked great for you you gained a
lot of followers
yeah yeah i gained a lot of followers
but it was a slow grind i mean it's like
how many followers did you have at that
point
on instagram he said he got hundreds of
followers
so i was i was doing two to three
liquor slams drinking stunts that i i
took myself to 110
where it's like like right now like i
can't even go into the mindset that i
was in back then because back then i was
hungry hungry not that i'm not hungry
right now
but like right now it's like i got
everything in the world
like back then i had nothing it was like
it's i couldn't even
at all you can eat wings i couldn't even
afford the ranch
you know what i'm saying so it was a
different level
of hungriness if you know what i'm
saying so it's like i literally
had drinking superpowers
like because it was like i was at a
whole nother level like
i was here it was like all you can eat
wings i couldn't even afford ranch
so it was it was at a whole other level
of hungriness to where it's like
i legit had super powers yeah i do not
possess
now i have i have them but they're not
at the cape back then bro i could do
anything i feel like anything you all
right
how much of uh i mean i guess i know the
answer to this i was going to say how
much of is alcohol like part of the deal
but my editor was telling me he's like
dude that guy's deal is just
[ __ ] alcoholic drinks like uh no i'm
trying i'm trying
i mean that's that was like before but
right now i like i don't i don't have to
drink like that to
to get what i got uh
i drink because it you felt like you
needed to drink to do a podcast
yeah i do because i have uh i feel like
i have autism i i may or may not i
mean why do you feel like you have
autism because i feel like um
i feel like i'm i'm very dumb but at the
same time i'm the
i i always call myself i always call
myself this i'm the
the the dumbest genius in the world all
right
because it's a fact that people who
think they're smart
are the dumber people yeah and actually
smart people think they're dumb
yeah so i actually think i'm the
stupidest person in the world but at the
same time i have
something special in this autism brain
of mine all right
so what are you doing now in l.a in
allie we live in orange county
so uh we just have the full sun house
knuck boys house i just film
whatever content i have to film with me
and milk but that's
but i uh i prefer to live in florida
florida miami
yeah miami my mom and dad live in
orlando very close with them so i like
to be
you know close to them and also i i i
just love florida i mean there's
the people everything florida is my
place florida is my pa
my place to be i i can't live my life in
california you know
i'm i'm a florida person all right now
let me ask you this dude because i'm so
i'm i'm generally pretty jealous of you
okay like
don't do it i mean
i'm profoundly grateful for everything
that i've accomplished i wouldn't change
anything in my life yeah you know except
maybe the poo cannon i would have put a
[ __ ]
earplug in there maybe jesus christ i
could have promoted some headphones dude
i could like anything anything but the
way my ear got rocked
um but in any case so we're both huge
ufc fans this weekend you know i'm
giving away when we recorded this but
we're going to the mcgregor
yes um that's not good dude i know dude
oh [ __ ] it's like you know where we're
changing elevations in a plane it's like
yeah but we're not on a plane
i know dude um so how did you end up
on the private jet
all the way to abu dhabi for
fight island in the middle of the
pandemic when they had no fans like
on so many levels that's unbelievable
but a private jet is
is a considerably bigger deal when it's
traveling
that far because um my assistant right
now
do you guys know bob metery no he works
he's the voice of buffalo wild wings but
he he's crazy in the head so basically
bob memory bob mannery uh called dana
white
with with kyle and everything and then
his his sons went crazy
oh dana white crazy and it was like
dana's like yo
my sons have met every celebrity there
is and they have never went crazy like
this for anybody
who the [ __ ] are you right like who the
[ __ ] are you
and then basically it's like yeah we're
the knock boys this and that and then we
became like
we became like best friends with dana
like for like dana feels like he's like
a second father to me
right dude epic it's crazy yeah so that
that's what happened and then
so dana just kind of takes care of us
for anything and everything we need
he's because he's we're just we're so
close with them
for some reason it just kind of happened
we just kind of built this like crazy
relationship
it's like how was that flying on the
private jet to abu dhabi oh
insane i mean it's like what the [ __ ] am
i doing i'm you know i just came as this
guy that drinks i'm an idiot this and
that it's like i'm gonna a private plane
to abu dhabi
to be dana white's personal guest if
you're dana white's person i guess you
get treated like goddamn
[ __ ] kids i'm familiar with that yeah
i haven't been there
i haven't made it to a private jet but
uh but yeah dana's hooked me up dude and
i could
have made you a private jet i mean i've
been on private jets okay not dana
white's private jet yeah
yeah dana i'd like to consider him a bro
he's a bro he's been really good the
only thing i like about the
i love about dana is he just keeps it
real yeah he does
what he thinks he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the robots in the world right he
talks
he talks [ __ ] on the instagram comments
like yeah [ __ ] you too dude
yeah yeah we'll do anything like it's
like he's not influenced by these robots
in the world it's like
what danith what dana says is he says it
because that's what he truly thinks
it's not because he has to say it yeah
joe rogan put it best i think
dana gives zero [ __ ] zero [ __ ]
zero [ __ ] yeah man i love that that's
why i did that's why dana is gonna
i don't know if i should be hit but
dana's gonna i was so drunk yesterday i
was texting dana a bunch i was like yo
like
let's get akashi 69 tickets
[Laughter]
dude check it out he texts me the other
day steve will do it texts me he goes yo
dude can i facetime you real quick for
my vlog and i said [ __ ] yeah you can
so i pick up the facetime call and it's
him
sitting there with takashi six nine and
and i'm like
no way dude six nine i did a tattoo of
you
on someone and i [ __ ] texted it to
and and then like after after this
conversation i hung up later right and i
thought man i'm gonna be on steve will
do its vlog
like with six nine and i wonder like i
wonder like if
if if that's going to be something that
comes with the backlash because i've
seen people have
backlashes for associating themselves
with six
nine and i was like you know what [ __ ]
it i don't care i was stoked
i was stoked yeah what are the
backlashes from
this there was an nfl player i saw him
on tmz and he had like he brought like
six nine to his like workout
like something or other and all the
people were like dude dude
you know like you're done you can't hang
out with him why because he's ratted on
people
yeah now here's what i think about
ratting right
anybody in that situation
is going to rat like whether you're
talking about what you're going to spend
like
30 years and he was facing 69 years
69 was facing 69 years like were you
gonna go to prison for 69 years for your
your reputation you know no dude like
anybody's going to be a rat and if you
don't want to be a rat then like maybe
don't commit crime
that's like my deal you know like we're
12-step
guys so like we're like pretty careful
about not like screwing people over like
doing the wrong thing you know like
we like we probably aren't going to have
to rat on anybody because we're probably
not going to be facing a lot of prison
time
exactly yeah wha what were you guys
doing on the vlog
no we i don't know if i could talk about
this yeah you don't
you don't have to if you feel like that
no but i mean we'll talk about it
and and and he felt strongly that like
he's put it out there hanging out with
six nine and gotten
zero zero zero hate because um because
he's a nice guy
that was that's the thing six nights the
sweetest of guys
and he was really cool to me on the
facetime call too he was like oh dude
stevo you're a legend like he was really
said nice things and was uh were you
guys were you
can you talk about where you guys were
we're in cabo and um
yeah where's cabo we're hanging out
because we we became good friends
recently
but anyways the inaugural catfish right
sure yeah so there's a girl that thinks
she's in love with me now right
all that so uh neve wanted to facetime
me
and um about this girl named diamond
and she thinks she's in love with me so
that's what we were doing in mexico
we're just
face time with neve and gambling what's
the six nine tie in there
six times she thinks i grew up listening
to him in the gym
and like out and the thing was the thing
is about me is i was always promoting
six
nine and i was like when i was like i
was broke with zero dollars and [ __ ]
whatever and i was like i was posting on
instagram it was like it was like
[ __ ] you i literally post the captions
like [ __ ] you guys like
i don't give a [ __ ] if you guys don't
like six nine but when i'm in the gym i
listen to six nine so i love this guy
i remember that so so so for me to be
posting that [ __ ]
and then me being like best buddies with
him now it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] with no no i like to
take that stance too man you know like i
like to be more of a dana white type
person if anybody has a [ __ ] problem
then
[ __ ] off but that's what i'm saying like
like for me like i
grew up and i loved his music like
i listened to six nine through what's
[ __ ] sixteen
thousand sixteen thousand bench press
sets you know i'm saying it's like
i'm not gonna change you know it's like
i'm not gonna change up on him now just
because
like right he did he did something that
the result was
he was not in jail like i'm not gonna
change up on him sure i
saw his uh he like shattered records
doing an instagram live
like when he yeah when he got
right and on that instagram live he was
saying like well dude these except what
i'm going to be loyal to these people
how the [ __ ] were they loyal to me
you know he was uh he said these guys
kidnapped me they pistol with me like
what i'm going to protect them and like
go to prison for them they weren't loyal
to me and yeah if that's all true it's
like
why would you right right and even if
it's not true
like if and i'm telling you anybody
who's facing that much prison time
is gonna cooperate to to not go to
prison like that's just human nature
it's like
oh [ __ ] yeah like shotgun
with a poop cannon yeah yeah my [ __ ]
you're never gonna do that again huh i'm
never going to do that again dude this
is new
that was that that was epic though i was
not did you see the clip i texted you
yeah that [ __ ] was epic it was
unbelievable
i did not think it would be that epic
that she was crazy
he was coming over and i was like man
i'm gonna hit a home run for this
this dude because like but i told you
this
that uh i had um the jackass like
one of the jackass producers this lady
shawna
she calls me up and she says you are the
biggest deal in my house
right now not because you have the
number one hot sauce on amazon or
you did not because you had three number
one movies in the box office
not because you this or that or anything
else but
you are the [ __ ] in my house right now
because you're in an elk boys video
and i heard about it from so many
different people just when we bumped
into each other at the ufc fight
i heard about it from so many people
scott heard about it from somebody i get
girls text me like hey you should meet
up with steve we'll do it and do a
podcast with them like what
that's crazy yeah i mean dude what is
this of the milk boys
you know that you're killing it and dude
so when you said hey
you want to come over and film a blog
like yes not only will i film a vlog
with you but i will pull out
something i will go big to to make it
count you know
and now you're going to the hospital
after this
yeah i thought we were just going to
film it my plan was just like say like
yo i love you you're amazing like and
that's it like just meet you on camera
again
but we did the the yeah the people yeah
i'm gonna do a game respects game
dude yeah you know like i i could i
could have been like oh hey i get to be
on camera what's up hello everyone and
i'm like no dude i'm gonna hit a home
run i told you that
yeah you did tell me i literally thought
you meant like
we're going to hit a home run dude we're
going to listen i really thought we were
going to play baseball
we'll go back to the autism thing that's
i literally thought we were going to
play baseball
uh yeah i i planned on on going big for
you
and i did and my ears really [ __ ]
hurts right now um
what so what about the chicks dude you
got a girl
diamond this is funny
we're not gonna go there no no let's go
there okay no the thing is
no i had a chick for like five years
whatever we we broke up yeah
and then i started talking to this new
chick and then she told
it's kind of funny because like bro i
loved her bro
like just recently your ex-girlfriend or
your new one the new one you love both
of them i love both of them but the new
one was like the best bro
and then the thing is like i have this
business partner in mind that like we're
like tight like this we're best friends
i was like
when i drink with him it's not like yo
let's drink and gets [ __ ] up
let's drink and let's celebrate what the
[ __ ] we did yeah like yo we got
millions of dollars wait let's celebrate
so when she told me like when she was
screaming at me for hanging out with him
so much
i left my condo never talked to her
again i was like
[ __ ] you never i will never ever ever
talk to you again
and that's how it is because because if
you want if you want if you want to be
with me like
like yo like i won't cheat on you this
and that but it's like you got to let me
live my life because like yo
i'm steve will do it llc like i gotta i
gotta do this i gotta do that
like he said he said i'm steve will do
an llc
that's what was in my head i mean you're
about business dude i get it
no you know i'm not i'm not hanging out
with anybody that's getting
in the way of me accomplishing that's
what i'm saying like if you're [ __ ]
with my billions
how many millions do you have right now
you know
no we can't talk about it the thing is
that's that's a very direct question
yeah yeah so
we can't talk about that it's like i
spend a million right
i make a million and whatever you know
it's so easy right what's the most
you've ever
spent in one day probably a million
dollars
a million dollars want me that's
mind-boggling to me
pure account yeah a million dollars
multiple times just because of
property or no two million dollars
because of property but buying real
estate but like giving away chains or
bitcoins
a million yeah well it's because i
bought myself 600 000 in watches and
then
gave away a hundred thousand and then
what the [ __ ] else did i do i did some
other [ __ ]
22 years old it's insane
so talk to me about milk boys merch how
does that work
full send well yeah we should we drop
merch
every every two months and it's just
limited limited stock
how about like uh what kind of quantity
for a limited drop
i have no idea see i'm the guy that's
just like
i don't want to know all that like yo
i'll put up the numbers
i'll make the money and this i was like
i don't i don't want to know
anything because that's how i work with
like with with with all my money and
this and that it's like i don't want to
think about
any any of that i have my mom deal with
everything
your mom everything everything yeah yeah
so my mom is like
you have someone i trust but like i
don't like to think about like okay so
when people buy these limited drops how
do the uh
orders get fulfilled like where does it
ship out from
oh yeah you're asking the wrong guy yeah
i really give zero [ __ ] i'm just i'm
just here to [ __ ] sell it
do you sign off on what gets sold no
designs
i don't sign off on anything i i have a
designer that sends me [ __ ] i'm like yo
that
that's fire that's not but every time
it's fire so it's like i never even have
to say yo that's not fire
because he every time it's like that's
amazing so i'm just kind of there
i i like being i like i like doing and
focusing what i'm good at right
which is just being me marketing i don't
like thinking about
numbers this that that's so funny dude
when i was like
27 28 i was like i had these like
like uh arguably crooked ass
people in charge of my business affairs
you know like uh
and i was like dad i'm the creative guy
man i let these guys do the numbers
he said so they're doing the numbers all
right yeah hey you can't have that
because you got
for me it's like i have my mother doing
it it's like you know yeah uh
you know it's like it's like my my exit
plan in life is like [ __ ] our seltzer
it's like who
dude and it seems like it's going pretty
well i put that four ways with the milk
the other knuck boys uh it's a
complicated there's a lot
because i mean can i talk about no okay
yeah good i'm glad you've got your
babysitter to make sure that you don't
step out of line no are we good are we
good
so far good okay yeah we're good but
yeah it's splitted
equally in a way that makes sense not
that it's actually equally but
everything makes sense yeah right okay
what age do you want to retire do you
have that age in mind that number
now if you ask me retirement can mean a
lot of things
like it could be going to bed at night
it could mean
settling down with just one lady like i
did
and like my editor mario did now here's
something very interesting it was while
editing an
episode of this podcast that mario first
found out about
blue chew tablets what are they well
they're delicious
chewable tablets which contain the same
active ingredient
as both viagra and cialis except of
course they're chewable
and they cost only a fraction of the
price so mario is interested enough to
sign up and get himself some
and i'm telling you he's been going
crazy about him haven't you
dude not only did it make me hard as a
rock my chick super digs it and i think
you guys should definitely get it
yeah my girl absolutely loves them too
and i'm telling you dude they're a lot
of fun so how do you get them
well for starters you don't have to go
to some doctor's office for an awkward
in-person visit nope
you go to bluechewed.com and you consult
with one of their medical professionals
and in no time they get you set up and
they send the tablets right to your
house
the best part is that if you use the
promo code stevo at checkout
you get an entire month's supply for
free that's right for free all you got
to pay is five bucks for
shipping so dude get on over to
bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo and enjoy an
entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets which make you hard as
a rock yeah dude you're gonna thank me
for it
now let's talk retirement i'm 22.
i should be able to retire by 24 but i'm
going to keep working until
till at least yeah dana white could
retire but
yeah i don't love your job i mean
right now i could retire and live a
comfortable life i
i guess right um
but you know what's crazy though is that
that uh
the the more money people have the more
financially insecure they feel it's
great they did like studies
people with over 10 million dollars
report feeling like more financially
insecure
than people with under 1 million that's
the thing once
for me too it's like you get a hundred
thousand it's like
that's it's such an accomplishment but
then you get use it for a while it's
like i want more
you get a million dollars you get it's
such an accomplishment then you get used
to it's like i want more you get
five million such an accomplishment you
want more and it just keeps going and
going it's like
that's how it is for me it's like i want
more and more and more like
like i'm at the point like i want a
billion that's good
like if if if i don't get a billion then
i fail because like
i think you're like i want 2 billion but
once i get a billion then it's like i
feel like i'm good but at the same time
once i get a billion it's like
[ __ ] this i want 10 billion you're like
dude [ __ ] mark zuckerberg says more
than i do
yeah that guy um you said that you uh
you wanted to do something to help dogs
i love that i love that you knew that i
love dogs
i do because i adopted uh two pit bulls
when i was growing up um it's a lot of i
just love pit bulls for some reason i
was loving the death and they did
they became my mom's uh like my mom's
sons
like my mom like those two pit bulls i
adopted are legit my mom's like
kids does your mom live in orange county
with you no she lives in florida
i'm saying yes so she would literally do
anything for those guys
and just for me just like i just know
like how it works like there's so many
pitbulls out there there's so many
getting put out there it's tough and
there's so many so just like
i love dogs it's like i just want to do
what i can like right now so i text you
it's like
yo i have a hundred thousand dollars
right
just to give to the dogs i have no idea
how i can help dogs with a hundred
thousand dollars but it's like
if i can if i can save like 50 dogs life
with a hundred thousand dollars like
yeah what do you do with a hundred
thousand dollars to save dogs
that's what i'm saying that's where
that's where i'm at like yo like i'm
ready to do
anything it takes like i have a hundred
grand to put up and it's like i wanna
help dogs i mean it's like frankly uh
is it like putting on an event and
having people come and adopt them
i think that um animal shelters in
general
are uh pretty under funded
you know like they're they're kind of
scraping by and um
if you were to go to like say north
central animal shelter and give him a
hundred thousand it would
probably change the you know the game
over there
it would help it would help a lot yeah
so that's something that me
me you and wendy can go do yeah dude i
love it man
i do i'm down i'm down to get red dude
and uh
today we was was like one idea we kind
of
threw it together we [ __ ] up my ear
real bad
but i told you the other idea i'm not
i'm not putting it out there because i
don't want to
i don't want people to [ __ ] shoot my
[ __ ] before i do
but uh i'm stubborn start to i'm stuck
too it's a great idea man
howard so you're going to reno before
the mcgregor fight
and then so presumably you're just
flying from vegas back to
orange county no miami miami oh you're
going to miami from there
yeah yeah i have a place in miami i love
miami you just stay there for a while
you just
i stay in miami as long as possible
until my
superiors like kyle and [ __ ] they tell
me like yo we need you
i'm there all right so this is this is
this is pretty uh
fortunate that we got to do this man by
the way i know it's a big ass deal for
you to do a podcast
yeah i don't thank you for this you know
like people have been begging for it
like you in knoxville i get the most you
know
me see it's so crazy hearing that people
like [ __ ] with me that much because it's
just like i'm just me you know what i'm
saying it's like why why the hell do you
like me so much
but it's a beautiful thing that's cool
bad dude
i always figure like you must been
somebody really good in the past life to
get to where you are now
you know i always think that about
people you think so yeah you're
you're probably a really really good
person in your past life
yeah you're telling them you're trying
to [ __ ] you in this life no no
no you're you're you're an amazing
person in this life because probably you
went through some [ __ ] in a past life
i don't that's what i always think about
people that have good lives now
i love that i do love that yeah thank
you
nah nah like dude and don't take this
question
uh wrong or as i'm being a dick but i'm
legitimately curious dude with the
drinking do you feel
like man maybe because we're both sober
guys we
drank way too much and we had to stop
like do you think that
at some point you're like or do you feel
like man i'm hitting it so hard with the
alcohol at some point like i'm probably
gonna [ __ ]
have to ask my bro stevo about hey how
do you [ __ ] put down the booze
no just because like
i don't love to drink that much like
that but it's kind of like
it it helps now i mean when you showed
up
i mean i like it but it's not like it's
not like i need it right
like you showed up at my house you were
straight chugging howler head
it was impressive but you you checked so
much and so when i was like no no please
stop stop stop
no i don't care if people drink yeah it
doesn't offend me
no but we have we have nothing to worry
about if i want to stop drinking i
i truly believe i can stop drinking
because it's not like
smoking weed different story i don't
think i never thought i did
i didn't think i could ever stop smoking
i missed smoking weed the most dude
i don't think i could have ever spot
stop smoking weed
period but like drinking i could and
it's like i'm at the point where it's
like i take such good care of myself
do you have the same daily routine every
day yeah for the most part yeah i work
out as much as possible and then just
if i have to film film and if not
stream and what do you stream on
uh i stream on twitch man i keep hearing
about that people make insane amounts of
money on twitch
yeah it's not it's not crazy money
but um you could make crazy money i feel
like
i don't play video games you can gamble
like i do i gamble
all right i don't care but if you want
to gamble
off camera off camera off camera i could
do this for
we set that up for you man i can talk to
you forever dude let me tell you this
that
i'm like profoundly honored
that you were willing to do my podcast
when you're unwilling to do
anybody else's no my i told you my
favorite podcast in the world i listened
to tim dillon
tim dillon he asked me months ago yeah
months ago like do whatever joe rogan
asked you
i would have done i would do it now but
months ago i wouldn't do it
i would do it now but months ago i
wasn't ready but now it's like yo we
have all day
so what i'm hearing is that uh
that the way to expand your comfort zone
is to get out of your comfort zone
you know like you didn't feel
comfortable doing a podcast and then
you said [ __ ] it dude i respect stevo
i'm gonna do his podcast you know i
don't want to
i'm gonna drink a little extra but and
then here we did it and it wasn't so bad
and now like you're thinking man maybe i
could do another one
no exactly but with you it's like
a whole nother level of respect well
thanks man i appreciate it you don't
understand like
how many times like i've re-watched the
jackass movie you know what i'm saying
like
dude we to get you uh special tickets to
the premiere
for our new jackass for i would love
that
to be here you and dana me and
uncle dana yeah yeah dude uncle dana
maybe we will be there but it's
it's life's crazy man life is crazy just
to be with you just to be here with you
and then you showing me the the kind of
respect and love that you do
why are you damn crazy you're on fire
man you're on fire
and uh people have been begging for it
and and dude we connected we
started texting and [ __ ] and like we're
bros dude
if i could put it there that's crazy i
would do what get him on the tattoo show
too
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna [ __ ] up that hand
you said
yeah he's down for some pretty dumb
tattoos too steve is gonna [ __ ] up my
hand
hell yeah well hey brother steve will do
it man [ __ ] thank you for the good
guys
oh you're the man dude thank you right
no i appreciate you guys it's just crazy
did i tell you or what man i wouldn't be
surprised if this ends up being our
our most uh downloaded and watched
episode ever
of course maybe i'm wrong who knows but
i'll tell you what i'm sure about
is that you for sticking around until
the very end
are the people who i am most grateful
for
i mean that and i'm not even going to
tell you anything except
i love you so thanks for [ __ ]
watching and listening and all that yeah